[Musik]
die Welt befindet sich im Umbruch die
Rolle der Vereinigten Staaten als
jahrzehntelange hegemonialmcht wird
schwächer andere Staaten wie China und
Indien aber auch der globale Süden
insgesamt gewinnen rasant an Bedeutung
wie soll sich Europa in dieser neuen
konstell hten haben wir es mit einer
systemischen Rivalität zu tun in der die
alte Weltordnung gegen gefährliche
Autokratien verteidigt werden muss oder
kann man die gegenwärtige Krisen und
Umbruchsituation auch ganz anders
beschreiben darüber rede ich mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler und
Politikberater Ivan
krast Herr KR viele Menschen in Europa
schauen heuteus en pessimistisch in die
Gegenwart und in die Zukunft der
russische Angriff auf die Ukraine der
Krieg im Nahen Osten Schein jede
menschheitsforschritt hohen zu sprechen
teilen Sie diese Sicht oder haben sie
gleich wohl
Zuversicht ich bin kein Mensch der
blinden Zuversicht aber ich bin auch
kein Pessimist Optimisten und
Pessimisten meinen die Zukunft zu kennen
so einer bin ich
nicht das heißt empfinden beide
Positionen in gewisser Hinsicht als
Arroganz weil man meint etwas über die
Zukunft zu wissen was man nicht wissen
kann ganz genau das Problem mit der
Zukunft ist doch dass sie immer
überraschendes berei hält gerade
momentan verändert sich die Welt so
unglaublich schnell da ist es für viele
schmerzhaft erkennen zu müssen dass Ihre
Vorstellungen von der Zukunft überhaupt
nichts mit den realen Entwicklungen zu
tun
haben aber deswegen jetzt den totalen
Pessimismus zu Verf ist auch nicht
gerechtfertigt denn so viel schlechter
sind die Zukunftsaussichten nicht
geworden für uns stimmt das vielleicht
noch aber für die meisten anderen
Menschen dieser Erde war die Welt von
gestern auch nicht gerade ein blühendes
Paradies könnte es nicht einfach sein
dass die der Pessimismus den wir heute
haben die Folge einer großen
Enttäuschung ist gerade in Ländern in
Europa auch in den Vereinigten Staaten
als man gedacht hat dass nach dem Ende
des Kalten Krieges der große Siegeszug
der liberalen Demokratien anhetzt und
tatsächlich ist es ja auch so gewesen
dass zunächst in den 90er Jahren sehr
vieles dafür gesprochen hat dann hat
sich etwas sehr sehr stark verändert wir
haben heute eine starke Zunahme
nichtdemokratischer Systeme oder
scheindemokratischer Systeme äh das
große Zeitalter der liberalen
Demokratien scheint nicht zu kommen
sondern wir sind stattdessen damit
konfrontiert dass die Welt sich in eine
ganz andere Richtung bewegt was glauben
sie sind die Hauptursachen dafür dass
diese Erwartungshaltung die die Länder
des Westens gehabt haben dass die
enttäuscht
wurde da haben sie recht ich glaube
dieser Pessimismus hat verschiedene
Ursachen die eine ist dass wir eine
alternde Gesellschaft sind und ältere
Menschen sind in der Regel weniger
optimistisch als jüngere die Jüngeren
haben einfach noch mehr Lebenszeit vor
sich zweitens haben wir in höchstem
Wohlstand gelebt besonders in Westeuropa
herrschte materieller Reichtum undürlich
meinten wir die Zukunft heraussehen zu
können nämlich eine Welt in der Europa
alles um sich herum nach seinem Vorbild
umgestalten
würde wir mussten plötzlich einsehen
dass das größte Problem darin besteht zu
verhindern dass andere uns umgestalten
ein echter Wandel in so einer Zeit
tiefgreifenden Wandels sind diejenigen
am verwundbarsten die schon sehr früh zu
den Gewinnern zählten genau das passiert
gerade in Europa insbesondere in
Deutschland der deutsche diplomat B hat
einmal etwas gesagt was ich sehr
treffend fand nämlich das Ende der
Geschichte von Francis Fukuyama war ein
amerikanisches Buch aber eine deutsche
Realität man hofft doch immer dass die
Welt die man versteht die Welt in der es
einem gut geht und von der man im Großen
und Ganzen weiß wie sie sich dreht
dauernd so bleibt aber die Welt ist in
Veränderung begriffen auf der
Siegerseite zu stehen ist die
ungünstigste Position wenn sich die Lage
zu verändern beginnt denn man hat ja
etwas zu
verlieren und dann gibt es junge
Menschen die befürchten dass sie nicht
dasselbe Leben wie ihre Eltern führen
werden es ist doch paradox
1968 gingen die jungen Leute auf die
Straße und verkündeten ich will nicht so
leben wie meine Eltern heute gehen Sie
auf die Straße und verlangen ich möchte
so leben wie meine
Eltern und dann ist da noch das
Klimathema das der jüngeren Bevölkerung
wirklich Angst einjagt die jungen Leute
sind sich eine kleine Gruppe sie fühlen
sich auf der Seite des Guten aber Sie
fühlen sich auch ohnmächtig sie sind
nicht zahlreich genug es gibt zu viele
alte und in der Demokratie kommt es nun
mal auf die Zahlen an all das zusammen
schafft ein Gefühl des Chaos dabei
sollte man nicht vergessen was ein
berühmter portugiesischer Schriftsteller
sagte Chaos ist bloß eine Ordnung die
darauf wartet entschlüsselt zu
werden lassen Sie uns zunächst mal
anfangen mit den großen geopolitischen
Veränderungen die sie auch jetzt
angesprochen haben sie haben gesagt wir
hatten geglaub nach Ende des Kalten
Krieges ein American book Franzis
fukoyama es käme das Ende der Geschichte
stattdessen kam das Ende unserer
Geschichte ja wie wir sie bisher
verstanden haben ja es ist also nicht
das Ende der Geschichte gekommen sondern
vielleicht das Ende einer bestimmten
Erzählung gekommen die wir bislang von
der Welt gehabt haben also eigentlich
das Gegenteil von von dem was wir
erwartet haben was sich sehr stark
verändert hat und was vielleicht nach
Ende des Kalten Krieges gar nicht
absehbar war ist dass die Bedeutung der
Vereinigten Staaten als große
Hegemonialmacht
langsam schwindet während sich die
asiatische Platte hebt ja und andere
Länder China Indien vielleicht auch
irgendwann die afrikanischen Länder od
der Iran oder Brasilien größere
internationale Bedeutung bekommen und
zwar nicht nur ökonomisch sondern eben
auch politisch
das stellt uns ja in unserem
Selbstverständnis vor eine große
Herausforderung und es ist eine nicht
ungefährliche Zeit vorher war die Welt
zwar vielleicht nicht gut aber sie war
sehr aufgeräumt jetzt kommen wir in eine
Situation der Unordnung wir reden von
die multipolare Weltordnung ist nicht
austariert wir wissen nicht genau wie
das sein wird wer sich durchsetzt welche
großen Folgen das haben muss wie geht
man in solchen Situationen der
Unsicherheit am klügsten damit um
am glügsten ist es sich zunächst einmal
klar zumachen dass da etwas zu Ende
gegangen ist und zwar aus plausiblen
Grunden paradoxerweise versuchen zwar
jetzt manche Spott über Fukuyama
auszuschütten aber in vielerlei Hinsicht
hatte er grundsätzlich Recht die Staaten
der Welt sind jetzt in hohem Maße
demokratisiert und selbst die Tatsache
dass wir neue Mächte Aufstreben sehen
hängt auch damit zusammen dass die
Menschen fast überall auf der Welt das
Wahlrecht haben wussten sie in den
nächsten 14 Monaten 4 Milliarden
Menschen bei verschiedenen Wahlen ihre
Stimme
abgeben außerdem ist die zeitspane in
der man einen technologischen Vorsprung
zu seinem ökonomischen Vorteil nutzen
kann geschrumpft nehmen wir irgendeine
Innovation die die Wirtschaft verändert
früher konnte man 10 Jahre lang davon
profitieren heute wird eine solche
Innovation in Z oder D Jahren
nachget hat also sehr an Tempo
zugelegt das liegt natürlich auch daran
dass die Menschen mobiler geworden sind
und sich umschauen wie man anderswo lebt
und dann werden Vergleiche
gezogen ich denke dabei immer an eine
Umfrage die mich vor d Jahren sehr
beeindruckt hat wenn man in den 1980er
Jahren hinschaute wie glücklich die
Menschen in der Welt waren wenn man
ihnen dazu Fragen stellte war der
Lebensstandard nicht der wichtigste
indikat
damals waren die Nigerianer genauso
glücklich wie die Deutschen und wissen
Sie warum die Nigerianer hatten keine
Ahnung davon wie die Deutschen lebten Z
war die Zeit vor dem Fernsehen als man
im Grunde noch nicht wusste was in der
Welt möglich und was unmöglich ist jetzt
leben wir in einer völlig anderen Welt
das hat zufolge dass ich das Verständnis
von macht tiefgreifend verändert im
Grunde genommen messen wir die Macht
daran wie hoch die Militärausgaben sind
welche Waffen man hat aber es geht auch
darum wie bereit deine Gesellschaft ist
diese Waffen auch einzusetzen wie bereit
du bist Opfer zu bringen oder
nicht ich glaube dass wir in der
Außenpolitik jetzt etwas erleben was wir
zuvor in der Innenpolitik gesehen haben
und das ist die größere Bedeutung der
Identitätspolitik schauen Sie sich all
diese Länder an Indien Brasilien als
Russland in die Ukraine einmarschierte
erwarteten wir dass all diese Länder
über das Ausmaß dieser Störung der
Weltordnung schockiert und sich mit uns
verbünden würden um eine freiheitliche
regelbasierte Ordnung zu
verteidigen ich glaube zwar nicht dass
vielen dieser Länder gefällt was
Russland gerade anstellt aber sie
argumentieren erstens dass dieser
Einmarsch nicht so außergewöhnlich ist
wie er uns erscheint sie sagen ihr zeigt
euch jetzt so stark betroffen weil es in
Europa passiert aber es ist die ganze
Zeit auch anderswo passiert zweitens es
gibt auch eine Art geographischen
Neid der indische Außenminister sagte
warum ist etwas wichtig nur weil es in
Europa passiert ist aber drittens sehen
Sie auch eine Chance für sich jetzt wo
wir so tun als ob diese Länder Zaungäste
wären die versuchen müssten sich
entweder auf die Seite der Vereinigten
Staaten und Europas oder auf die Seite
Chinas und Russlands zu stellen schauen
wir uns diese Länder doch einmal an sie
hocken nicht herum oder haben Sie das
Gefühl dass Präsident Erdogan bloß da
sitzt er läuft doch und läuft er
versucht bei jeder Hochzeit die Braut
und bei jeder Beerdigung die Leiche zu
sein so gesehen sind diese Menschen und
diese Länder höchst aktiv sie versuchen
ihr Gewicht geltend zu machen und so
ihre weltpolitische Bedeutung zu erhöhen
sie machen sich keine Sorgen über den
Zustand der Welt denn was sie wirklich
interessiert ist ihr Platz in der Welt
diese Gemengelage verändert sich derzeit
dramatisch ich mag mich irren aber meine
Erwartung ist folgende während sich
viele Staaten auf die Vereinigten
Staaten und China konzentrieren und
abwarten wie sie die Welt gestalten
werden während wir im Kopf zu einer
Neuauflage des Kalten Krieges
zurückkehren werden andere Länder die
Saudis Südafrika all diese regionalen
Mächte geradezu hyperaktiv sein und in
ganz verschiedene Richtungen laufen es
ist eine Bewegung der
blockfreiheit die genannten Länder
werden das internationale Umfeld viel
stärker prägen als bisher Europa hat
lange gesagt wir mögen die multipolare
Welt wir inten wir den Multilateralismus
wenn nämlich eine überschaubare Anzahl
von Staaten
zusammenarbeitet die multipolare Welt
wird unübersichtlicher sein weil viele
Länder eine Rolle spielen sie werden
ziemlich unberechenbar sein deshalb
befinden wir uns in einer Situation in
der uns sozusagen an jeder Straßenecke
schon die nächste Überraschung
erwartet sie beschreiben ein Umbruch in
der Welt den wir immer noch aus einer
sehr alten Perspektive wahrnehmen wenn
wir sagen jene Länder die sich nicht
klar positionieren etwa beim Russland
ukrainekrieg oder sich nicht klar
positionieren im Verhältnis zwischen
China und den USA sie würden auf dem
Zaun sitzen also quasi zugucken und
nichts tun und sie beschreiben eine Welt
wo sie sagen das ist eigentlich das alte
Bild des Westens die erwarten dass sie
in einem westlichen Schema the West
against the rest ja dass sie dort Partei
ergreifen und sie beschreiben dass diese
Länder wie die Türkei z.B wie Südafrika
wie
Saudi-Arabien dass diese Länder
eigentlich gar nicht dieses Schema sehen
sondern sie haben eine Studie gemacht in
der Global Menschen in der Welt befragt
wurden wie sie die Welt sehen und das
Ergebnis zu dem sie kommen ist
dass Sie dass immer mehr eine
alakardptik ist das heißt diese Länder
greifen sich das eine raus mal das
andere sie bilden Partnerschaften
unterschiedliche Art und Weise keine
ideologischen oder weltanschaulichen
sondern ganz pragmatische
Partnerschaften auch über ideologische
Grenzen hinweg und dass wir aber den
Fehler machen immer noch wie in alten
Tagen zu Zeiten zu Sowjetzeiten des
Kalten Krieges immer noch eine
zweipolarität zu sehen wogegen die neuen
Länder diese zweipolarität überhaupt
nicht sehen sondern gucken wie sie sich
running wie sie sagen also in ständiger
Bewegung versuchen ihren Teil des Ganzen
irgendwo zu sichern und diese
Bipolarität aus Sicht der neuen Staaten
eigentlich der Vergangenheit angehört
aber diese Bipolarität prägt jede
Talkshow in
Deutschland dazu müssen wir erst einmal
verstehen was das Besondere am kalten
Krieg war wir sprechen über den Kalten
Krieg als hätte er sich nie
geändert dabei umfasste er eine lange
zeitspane und es gab auch verschiedene
Phasen
woher kam eigentlich die Stabilität des
Kalten Krieges sie beruhte auf
verschiedenen
Faktoren zum einen gab es Blöcke und die
großen Supermächte kontrollierten ihre
Einflusssphären zweitens waren es die
Atomwaffen die die internationale
Politik stark verändert und
diszipliniert
haben eine der wichtigsten
Voraussetzungen für Stabilität des
Kalten Krieges bestand in folgendem
beide Seiten der stische Kommunismus und
die Freiheitlichen Staaten des Westens
waren sich sicher dass sie das Modell
der Zukunft sein der Historiker und
Politikberater George Cannon sagte in
seiner berühmten Containment Theorie wir
sollten einfach abwarten am Ende würde
der Kommunismus ohn hin an seinen
eigenen Widersprüchen Zug Grunde gehen
aber wenn Sie die marxistische Literatur
lesen werden Sie feststellen dass die
sowjetische Seite dasselbe von uns
dachte der Kapitalismus wird schließlich
an seinen eigenen Widersprüchen Zug
Grunde gehen
deshalb lieber jetzt kein Krieg weil man
glaubte dass man morgen in einer
stärkeren Position sein wird der Kalte
Krieg war der Höhepunkt des westlichen
Einflusses weil beide Supermächte die
Quellen ihrer Ideologien in der
europäischen Aufklärung haben wer also
ist der legitime und wer der illegitime
Nachfahrer der Aufklärung beide
Ideologien waren sehr stark in Europa
verwurzelt KL Mar war kein russischer
Denker entglobalisierung und
Entkolonialisierung von Strukturen die
im Laufe des 20 Jahrhunderts entstanden
sind immer stärker im
Vordergrund was wir in unserer Studie
herausgefunden haben ist
folgendes insbesondere Länder wie Indien
oder Brasilien fühlen sich auf der Ebene
der Werte dem Westen näher wenn man die
Menschen fragt wer soll ihrer Meinung
nach das Internet regulieren die USA und
die EU oder China
werden Sie sich für die USA und die EU
entscheiden wenn man sie fragt wohin
wollen sie auswandern dann wählen Sie
Europa sie wollen nicht nach Russland
oder
China aber die Idee der Souveränität und
Souveränität ist das Schlüsselkonzept
dieser neuen multipolaren Welt bedeutet
für Sie dass Sie eine Wahl haben sie
wollen im Grunde eine Situation in der
ihr
sicherheitsgar staten sind ihr
wichtigster Handelspartner aber China
sein
wird so versetzen Sie sich selbst in die
Lage größtmöglicher Handlungsfreiheit
und das gilt sowohl für die Regierungen
als auch für die
Bevölkerung das ist eine ganz andere
Situation als im Kalten
Krieg der Kommunismus war eine radikale
Ideologie wenn man in Entwicklungsländer
schaut dann gab es zwei Dinge die dort
am
se radikalten erstens der Kommunismus
wollte Gott töten schon da entsteht ein
Konflikt mit einer traditionell
religiösen
Gesellschaft zweitens ging es im
Kommunismus um das Ende des
Privateigentums in gewisser Weise war
also von den beiden Formen der Moderne
der westlichen und der kommunistischen
die westliche Moderne die
[Musik]
konservative was sich nun geändert hat
ist dass China auch eine Form der Mod
stellt aber jetzt sind wir im Westen die
radikale
Variante so geht der Westen viel
liberaler mit sexuellen Normen und mit
Minderheiten um als konservativere
Gesellschaften außerhalb des
Westens und in Russland gibt es die
Mobilisierungskraft nicht mehr die der
Kommunismus während des Kalten Krieges
hatte um dieses Land am Leben zu
erhalten und von außen betrachtet sehen
die neuen aufstrebenden Länder Russland
ganz generell nicht mehr als mächtig
genug
an
müssen Brasilianer oder Inder etwa
Russland wirklich fürchten nein
infolgeedessen befinden wir uns in einer
anderen Welt in der anders als im Kalten
Krieg weder China oder Russland noch die
Vereinigten Staaten diese aufstrebenden
Mächte disziplinieren können sie werden
sich neu positionieren und das ist eine
interessante
Entwicklung als z.Bp der
russisch-ukrainische Krieg begann hatten
wir das Gefühl dass es sich um ein
globales Ereignis handelt und jetzt sagt
man uns ihr müsst schon selbst damit
klarkommen es ist ein regionaler Krieg
es ist ein europäischer Krieg er ist uns
eigentlich egal wir mögen zwar nicht was
die Russen tun aber wir werden uns nicht
grundsätzlich auf eure Seite
stellen dagegen konnte man sehen dass
beispielsweise die Aktivitäten in den
sozialen Medien während der ersten drei
Wochen des Krieges im Nahen Osten in
einem Land wie Brasilien viermal so
stark waren wie in den ersten drei
Wochen des russisch-ukrainischen Krieges
warum ist das so nun im Falle Brasiliens
weil Palästina in der antikolonialen
Erzählung einen sehr wichtigen Platz
einnimmt auf der anderen Seite nimmt
Israel für die evangelikale Gemeinschaft
in Brasilien einen sehr wichtigen Platz
ein so wurde aus einem räumlich sehr
begrenzten Krieg plötzlich ein globales
Ereignis wenn man schaut wie
Gesellschaften gespalten sind und wie
Menschen reagieren in Indien dagegen
haben 300.000 Menschen in den sozialen
Medien erklärt dass sie als freiwillige
israelische Armee gehen wollen
wahrscheinlich wissen sie nicht einmal
genau wo Gaza liegt aber es gibt diese
antimuslimische Stimmung in Indien die
selbst von der Regierung geschürt
wird es gibt die sozialen Medien die
Menschen haben eine Meinung und die
internationale Politik wird eigentlich
zur
Identitätspolitik indem man auf
bestimmte Konflikte reagiert reagiert
man nicht auf das was dort passiert
sondern man versucht herauszufinden wer
man selbst
ist das eine was natürlich sehr
interessantes ist wir haben uns ja von
der modernen Welt des
Internets ungefähr in der gleichen Phase
nach Ende des Kalten Krieges äh in der
die Vorstellung generiert wurde dass
alle Länder in Zukunft vielleicht
liberale Demokratien werden auch gehofft
dass die digitale Technik das Internet
die Menschen
zusammenbringt tatsächlich haben wir
gesehen die Menschen haben sehr sehr
viel mehr übereinander gelernt aber die
Welt ist nicht friedlicher geworden
dadurch dass die Menschen viel
übereinander gelernt werden mittlerwe
ist das Internet selbst ein
Kriegsschauplatz geworden ja ein ein
Schauplatz kognitiver Kriegsführung eine
Frage wer setzt dort seine narrative
durch im Grunde genommen ist die
Hoffnung dass wir auch mit Hilfe von
Technologie zum Siegeszug liberaler
Demokratien beitragen würden ja
ebenfalls eine enttäuschte Hoffnung vor
der wir stehen und jetzt gibt es so die
sehr sehr starke Reaktion die eine Art
leidnarrativ ist für die westlichen
Staaten zu sagen wir befinden uns heute
in einer systemischen Rivalität
gegenüber autokratischen Systemen sie
haben gerade eine Welt gezeichnet die
eine ganz andere Topografie hat nicht
eine Welt eine binäre Welt ja einer
systemischen Rivalität wie im Kalten
Krieg sondern eben diese
alakatwelt ja mit neuen Staaten die
versuchen zu ihrem zu kommen in
wechselnden Bündnissen und so weiter
dann würde ja eigentlich dieses narrativ
der systemischen Rivalität nicht
es ist ja handlungsleitend für uns aber
es würde nicht greifen könnte das ja
vielleicht auch damit erklären dass man
sagt haben wir wirklich eine systemische
Rivalität mit China missioniert China
versuchen wie im Kalten Krieg
Kommunismus meint er wäre das
überlegende System Kapitalismus meint er
wä das überlegende System glauben die
Chinesen dass Ihr System ein
Exportschlager ist ja und wahrscheinlich
ist es nicht der Fall wahrscheinlich
sind wir deswegen so große Rivalen mit
China heute weil China so kapitalistisch
agiert also ein
turbokapitalistisches china ist ein
größerer Rivale für die Länder des
Westens als eine kommunistische
Misswirtschaft trotzdem haben wir aber
dieses Bild aus dem Kalten Krieg ja
immer noch sehr stark im Kopf wir haben
es ja erst haben wir den
ostwestgegensatz Kommunismus
Kapitalismus übertragen auf die
Auseinandersetzung mit der islamischen
Welt ja als die Bücher erschienen von
Samuel Huntington der Clash der
Zivilisationen oder von Barber ja Jihad
versus mcworld wir haben ja wieder ein
binäres Schema aufgebaut und jetzt bauen
wir wieder ein binäres Schema auf
nämlich die liberalen Demokratien gegen
die Autokratien der Welt warum kommen
wir aus diesem binären Schema nicht raus
wenn es wie sie gerade beschrieben haben
die Realität so schlecht
trifft das ist wirklich kompliziert weil
es einen Unterschied zwischen
Demokratien und totalitären Regimen gibt
niemand möchte doch in China leben mal
abgesehen von der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung Regime haben ihre
Eigenheiten und ihre starken und
schwachen Seiten erinnern Sie sich an
die ersten se Monate der Pandemie als
alle China beneideten und dann die
letzten se Monate als niemand verstand
was sie
taten Demokratien haben dagegen einen
großen Vorteil der wichtig ist es
handelt sich um eine Regierungsform die
über einen Mechanismus zur
Selbstkorrektur verfügt das heißt nicht
dass wir immer die richtigen
Entscheidungen treffen aber in einer
Demokratie ist es viel einfer Politik zu
ändern wenn etwas falsch läuft in
autoritären Regierungsformen muss man
wenn man sich geirrt hat dennoch darauf
bestehen dass man im Recht ist weil eben
nun mal die Regierung immer im Recht
ist wenn ich also sage dass es keine
bipolare Welt mehr gibt heißt das nicht
dass es keine unterschiedlichen
Staatsformen gebe und dass sie nicht
alle ihre eigene Logik hätten das
Problem ist nur wenn man Brasilien oder
Indien die ja Demokratien sind
überzeugen möchte dass sie sich im
russischukrain Krieg sofort auf die
Seite des Westens Stellen sollen werden
sie das nicht machen warum machen sie
das nicht erstens liegt es daran dass
die Grenze zwischen Demokratie und
Autoritarismus die am wenigsten bewachte
Grenze der Welt ist es handelt sich
nicht um klassischer autoritäre Regime
mit Ausnahme von China gibt es keine
Kommunistische Partei die zumindest
erklärt dass sie Teil der
kommunistischen Ideologie ist viele
dieser autoritären Regime haben freie
Wahlen die aber wahrscheinlich nicht
das Problem mit dem Autoritarismus ist
genau das Gegenteil der Pornografie sie
kennen doch die berühmte Geschichte von
dem Richter der sagte ich weiß nicht was
Pornografie
ist genau ich werde sie erkennen wenn
ich sie sehe das Problem mit der
Autokratie ist genau das Gegenteil wir
können leicht sagen was Autokratie ist
aber wir sind nicht sicher ob wir sie
erkennen wenn wir sie
sehen recht wenn es um den Kapitalismus
geht gibt es natürlich auch verschiedene
Formen aber keine von ihnen ist eine
kommunistische Wirtschaft wie es die
sowjetische Wirtschaft
war und das ist es auch worum es bei
China geht China als Großmacht versucht
andere zu beeinflussen und insbesondere
versuchen die Chinesen die
Handelspolitik anderer Länder zu
kontrollieren aber wollen sie gleich
eine chinesische kommunistische Partei
in all diesen Ländern Gründen nein und
das ist die interessante Geschichte
genauso wie der westliche Liberalismus
war auch der sowjetische Kommunismus
universalistisch jeder glaubte dass
eines Tages die ganze Welt so sein würde
wie man selbst ich denke aber bei China
ist das genau anders herum sie glauben
dass niemand so sein kann wie
China sie glauben sehr stark an eine
chinesische
Ausnahmestellung was sie also im Grunde
zu exportieren versuchen ist nicht so
sehr eine Ideologie sondern Technologien
insbesondere für die Überwachung sie
asymmetrische Beziehungen zu anderen
Ländern auf und ich habe viel darüber
nachgedacht dass es zwischen den
Vereinigten Staaten und China einen sehr
wichtigen kulturellen Unterschied gibt
dessen wir uns vielleicht bewusst werden
sollten er hängt mit der Frage zusammen
wie lernen die USA und China die Welt
kennen die Vereinigten Staaten kennen
die Welt weil Menschen aus der ganzen
Welt dorthinkommen oder besser gesagt
das was die Vereinigten Staaten über die
Welt wissen ist wie man Bulgaren
deutsche und andere zu Amerikanern macht
woher kennt China die Welt durch
Chinatowns es gibt all diese Orte an
denen sie ihre Identität bewahren sie
bleiben im Zentrum der Stadt sie
versuchen nicht sich anzupassen sie
versuchen das Umfeld für sich zu nutzen
aber sie bleiben unter
sich und ich glaube dass man in den USA
die Welt zwar als etwas umzugestaltendes
sieht die Amerikaner aber viel mehr
daran interessiert sind was sie mit der
Welt machen können weil das ihre
kulturelle ung ist die Chinesen dagegen
sehen zu wie sie ihre eigene Welt nutzen
und schützen können der amerikanische
Politologe Samuel Huntington glaubte
dass die Kulturen sehr klare und stabile
Identitäten haben und gerade weil das so
ist geraten sie in Konflikt miteinander
ob Russland die Ukraine Israel Gaza man
kann gar nicht genau sagen ob es sich um
einen Bürgerkrieg oder einen Krieg der
Kulturen handelt und das Problem ist
dass alle wichtigen Kulturen auch ihre
Identitätskrisen haben es gibt ja so
etwas wie eine
identitätspanik im Falle Russlands ist
das sehr deutlich was bedeutet es nach
dem Ende der Sowjetunion Russe zu sein
wer sind die Russen aber sie sehen das
auch an anderer Stelle wenn sich Länder
z.B umbenennen wollen die Türkei heißt
jetzt türkie und so weiter diese Art von
Identitätskrise diese Panik ich weiß
nicht genau wer ich bin ist also nicht
der Kampf der Kulturen
untereinander wegen dieser
Verunsicherung gibt es diese Art von
höchster anspan
das ist wichtig denn unter diesem
Gesichtspunkt haben Autoren wie Hans
Magnus Enzensberger am Ende des Kalten
Krieges etwas erkannt die Tatsache dass
wir so etwas erleben dass wie ein
globaler Bürgerkrieg aussieht die
Trennlinien sind hier nicht so
eindeutig es gibt all diese Diasporas es
gibt die sozialen Medien in denen die
Spaltung im Grunde nicht nur zwischen
den Staaten sondern auch innerhalb der
Staaten
stattfindet und das führt zu diesem
Ausmaß an Unregierbarkeit und Chaos das
uns aus guten Gründen aller erschreckt
hat aber das lässt sich nicht so einfach
disziplinieren wie der Kalte Krieg die
Welt diszipliniert hat wenn das Tableau
was sie gerade beschreiben ja wenn das
so stimmt dann bedeutet das dass sich
durch die Globalisierung und durch das
Informationszeitalter die Staaten nicht
unbedingt einander angenähert haben
sondern dass sie vor allen Dingen
erstmal innenpolitische Identitätskrisen
bekommen haben weil sie nicht mehr
wissen wer sie sind ja und also sich
quasi neu erfinden müssen neu aufstellen
müssen mit all den Nachteilen die
Identitätspolitik natürlich auch hat
denn Identitätspolitik also das Bekennen
zu einer bestimmten Gruppe einem Volk
einer Nation natürlich auch immer mit
sich bringt dass man sich massiv
abgrenzt gegen andere was also nicht zur
global village führt im politischen
Sinne ja sondern dass so immer wieder
neuen Konfrontationen führt da stelle
ich mir natürlich die Frage diese sehr
wichtige politische außenpolitische
Frage Werte auf der einen Seite und
Interessen auf der anderen Seite ja wie
mischt sich das also welche Rolle
spielen in einer
alakatwelt ja wo jeder erstmal mit
seiner eigenen Identität beschäftigt ist
und sich wechselseitig rauspickt mit wem
eine nichtkatholische Ehe eingehen will
ja wie verträgt sich das mit dem
Wertebewusstsein der jeweiligen
Gesellschaft identty tität ist sehr
wichtig denn Identität heißt ich
versuche sie davon zu überzeugen mich so
zu sehen wie ich mich selbst sehe nach
dem ersten Treffen zwischen Präsident
Biden und Präsident Putin das vor dem
Krieg in der Ukraine stattfand sigerte
ein Bericht in die Medien durch diesem
Bericht zufolge sagte beiden zu Putin es
geht uns nicht um einen regimwechsel in
Russland aber wir werden nicht aufhören
über Menschenrechte und Demokratie zu
sprechen nicht weil wir sie ändern
wollen sondern weil wir nicht zulassen
werden dass sie uns ändern das ist das
was wir
sind unter diesem Gesichtspunkt ist es
wichtig zu sagen wer man ist aber auf
der anderen Seite ist es auch sehr
wichtig zu verstehen wie die anderen
sich selbst sehen denn anderenfalls und
das ist eines der Symptome die ich als
sehr beunruhigend empfinde tritt in der
Identitätspolitik sei es innenpolitisch
oder international eine gewisse Wildheit
an die Stelle von bereichenbarkeit
im Kalten Krieg haben Politiker selbst
wenn sie ihre Positionen dramatisch
änderten den Anschein vermittelt nicht
danach zu
handeln heute ist das wichtigste sehr
intensiv auf etwas zu beharren so merken
die Leute nicht wie sehr man seine
Positionen bereits verändert
hat denn funktioniert das mit der
Identitätspolitik grßmach sehen ein
Beispiel stellen Sie sich vor Sie sind
Saudi-Arabien auf der einen Seite
versuchen sie zu zeigen dass sie eine
moderne Nation sind sie erlauben Frauen
das Autofahren und im Grunde investieren
Sie mehr Geld in Klimaforschung als die
meisten westlichen
Nationen auf der anderen Seite behandeln
sie Menschen äußerst brutal sie töten
Journalisten und so
weiter aus dieser Sicht ist das
Wichtigste wenn man erfolgreich Politik
betreiben willine Identität zu
bewahren man sollte aber auch sorgfältig
darauf achten wie andere sich selbst
wahrnehmen das geschieht oft nicht dann
wird es richtig
spannend die meisten Länder im Nahen
Osten haben ein Interesse daran mit
Israel Handel zu treiben es ist
schließlich ein technologisch sehr
hochentwickelter
Nachbar auf der anderen Seite war die
Identität dieser Länder über die Jahre
hin weg auf einer sehr starken
antiisraelischen Stimmung gegründet wie
bringt man all das unter einen
Hut man wird nie zu richtigen
Einschätzungen kommen bevor man nicht in
jeder Krise Werte und Interessen neu
verhandelt und das ist sehr schwierig
denn einige Länder kommunizieren so als
ob sie nur an Geschäften interessiert
wären wenn man z.B China zuhört glaubt
man dass es dort nur um eigene
Interessen geht und nie um Werte aber
das stimmt nicht wenn man versucht zu
erkennen dass sie eigentlich nur ein
paar Dinge zu ihren Gunsten verändern
wollen und andere nicht auf der anderen
Seite die Europäische Union wenn man uns
zuhört haben wir anscheinend nur Werte
und keine Interessen wenn man sich aber
unsere Handelspolitik ansieht wird man
feststellen dass das nicht ganz der Fall
ist man muss sich z.B nur unseren Schutz
geistiger Eigentumsrechte ansehen und
wird schnell erkennen dass auch wir
unsere Interessen haben wir versuchen
unsere Industrien seit es geht zu
schützen man spricht von der Heuchelei
des Westens leider haben wir kein
Monopol auf diese Heuchelei ich glaube
dass alle Großmächte heuchlerisch sind
aber wir sind diejenigen die
universalistisch sprechen das heißt wir
sagen den Menschen immer dass wir uns um
das Wohl aller kümmern die Chinesen
werden entgegnen wir kümmern uns um
China die Russen werden sagen wenn sie
ehrlich sind wir kümmern uns nur um die
Russen aber wir sagen immer dass wir uns
um alle kümmern
das wird inzwischen stark in Zweifel
gezogen es wird als eine Art Doppelmoral
eben als Heuchelei und als
schulmeisterlich wahrgenommen hey was
ihr macht ist falsch und das Paradoxe
ist dass im Zeitalter der sozialen
Medien plötzlich der einzige den man
überhaupt noch vertraut der Zyniker
ist selbst wenn man nur seine Werte
verteidigen will spricht man inzwischen
oft von Interessen man glaubt sobald man
von Werten spricht vermuten viele
Menschen eine Lüge oder ein falsches
Spiel wir leben in einer Welt in der
richtiges Handeln sehr schwer
wird nun könnte man ja als Konsequenz
darausziehen und sagen wir sollten
aufhören unsere Interessen als Werte zu
verbrämen auf der anderen Seite ist ja
der universalistische Anspruch von
Werten eine sehr positive Errungenschaft
der Aufklärung insbesondere zurückgehend
auf imemmanuel Kant weil es die
Grundlage darstellt für das was wir aus
guten Gründen die Menschenrechte nennen
und die natürlich für uns ein sehr sehr
hohen Wert darstellen die Frage würde
jetzt darin bestehen wie kann man dem
universalistischen Anspruch der
Menschenrechte gerecht werden ohne sich
dem Verdacht auszusetzen ja die eigenen
Interessen nur als Werte zu verbrähmen
denn aufgeben kann man ja den
universalistischen Anspruch im Sinne der
Menschenrechte nicht das sollen sie ja
wahrscheinlich
len wenn ich die Antwort auf diese Frage
wüsste glauben sie mir dann würde es uns
allen besser gehen zunächst einmal wird
man kämpfen müssen und das war der
Kriegsgeneration sehr klar jemand wie is
Berlin würde sagen dass sie in dieser
Welt sehr selten zwischen Gut und Böse
wählen können jedesm wenn sie eine
Entscheidung treffen opfern sie einen
Wert ich glaube wir werden erkennen
müssen dass der Universalismus nicht
einfach unsere bedeutet der Schutz des
menschlichen Lebens ist ein Wert für
jeden in jeder einzelnen Kultur kann man
ihn
finden es sind keine westlichen
Werte es sind nicht allein die
westlichen Werte und es gibt bestimmte
Dinge auf die wir pauchen sollten
andererseits sollten wir nicht so tun
als ob alles auf das wir uns in unserer
Gesellschaft geeinigt haben auch
woanders die Norm sein sollte es gibt
Dinge über die sich Menschen intuitiv
einig sind z.B
Folter die berühmte amerikanische
politikphilosophin Judit schlar spricht
vom Liberalismus der Furcht und sie sagt
das Wichtigste sei keine Grausamkeiten
zuzulassen jede Gesellschaft versteht
dieses Gebot weil sie die
gemeinschaftsbildende Kraft dieses
Wertes
kennt Grausamkeit bedeutet in einer Welt
zu leben die unregierbar wird wenn wir
die Menschen glauben machen dass es
normal ist Menschen in Stücke zu
schneiden wenn es normal ist in die
sozialen Medien zu gehen und zu filmen
wie man Babys
tötet aber bedeutet das dass wir das
Recht haben alle Menschen in der Welt zu
belehren und zu bekehren etwa über
grundlegendes wie unsere Familienwerte
und so weiter Pressefreiheit
Versammlungsfreiheit das S wären
typische westliche Werte die es in
anderen
gleich Mae
gibt auch wenn sie ihren eigenen Weg
finden werden gibt es eben grundlegende
Werte auf die man nicht verzichten darf
wenn man z.B eine Demokratie sein will
sollte es Wahlen geben bei denen die
Opposition gewinnen kann das ist nur
eine
Mindestforderung wir sprechen nicht
darüber wie die Verfassung hier und da
aussehen sollte und wir glauben nicht
dass es unbedingt eine lupenreine
Demokratie sein muss aber aber wenn es
eine Demokratie gibt in der die
Machthaber niemals Wahlen verlieren
können und in der wenn sie Wahlen
verlieren die Macht nicht abgeben dann
ist dieses Land keine Demokratie
ungeachtet der Tatsache dass die
Menschen wählen gehen wenn man diese Art
von kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner findet
kann man sagen das ist es was das
gemeinsame Leben möglich macht auf der
anderen Seite gibt es viele Dinge die
für westliche Gesellschaften wichtig
sind und wir schätzen diese aus
verschiedenen historischen Gründen
teilen viele meist sekulare
Gesellschaften diese Werte noch denn in
der Welt haben die Religionen wieder
größeren Einfluss unsere Aufklärung
basierte auf einer bestimmten Art von
historischer Erfahrung die nicht
universell sein muss ich glaube nicht
dass Zivilisationen so beschaffen sind
dass man bei einer Autopsie den
Unterschied zwischen ihnen feststellen
könnte aber ich glaube sehr wohl dass
Erfahrungen in der Geschichte eine Rolle
spielen alle unsere Gesellschaften
beruhen auf bestimmten Ängsten und
Hoffnungen und die haben sich über
Generationen hinweg erhalten
anzuerkennen dass Menschen
unterschiedliche Erfahrungen machen
können ist etwas Sinnvolles wird diese
Einsicht unsere Politik einfach machen
nicht unbedingt aber wir sollten wissen
dass die Haltung wie sie Europa oft an
den Tag legt wirklich dramatisch
schiefläuft man kann nicht einfach
hingehen und Solidarität in einer Sache
verlangen wofür es auf der anderen Seite
kein Verständnis gibt man kann z.B zu
den Kataris nachdem der Krieg zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine begonnen hat
die deutsche Regierung ging hin und
sagte wir brauchen euer Gas und am
nächsten Tag sagt sie aber hört mal uns
gefällt nicht wie ihr eure Gesellschaft
regiert und so weiter das kann nicht
lange gut gehen denn irgendwann werden
sie einem entweder kein Gas mehr geben
oder man lenkt
ein wir sollten versuchen einen
Mittelweg zu finden indem wir sagen
wisst ihr es ist sehr wichtig das ist
unser Interesse und ich hoffe dass es in
eurem Interesse ist uns Gas zu verkaufen
das wird der Welt größeren Frieden
bringen jetzt nach Ausbruch des Krieges
und denkt daran wir sind nicht hier um
euch zu sagen wie ihr grundsätzlich alle
Frauen und Homosexuellen behandeln sollt
wir sind aber auch nicht hier um euer
Gesellschaftsmodell zu kopieren wir
machen so etwas nicht in unseren
Gesellschaften aber wir sind nicht hier
um euch zu sagen macht das so und so
sonst wollen wir nie wieder etwas mit
euch zu tun
haben
ich glaube dass es diesen Mittelweg mehr
und mehr geben wird weil einige dieser
Länder nicht nur wirtschaftlich und
militärisch stärker werden sie werden
auch viel selbstbewusster und viel
aggressiver werden und ehrlich gesagt
wenn man in dieser Welt lebt und
versucht sich selbst zu bestätigen und
machtbewusster aufzutreten ist es viel
einfacher dies gegenüber der
Europäischen Union zu tun als gegenüber
den Vereinigten
Staaten die Kosten einer Konfrontation
mit den Vereinigten Staaten sind viel
höher und ich glau
die euräische eine echte Herausforderung
sein
wir eine letzte Frage mit der Bitte um
eine vergleichsweise kurze Antwort auf
eine große Frage wir haben bisher eine
Werte basierte oder Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik vertreten die natürlich
besonders betont was Länder wie China
z.B oder Russland von Deutschland
trennt n leben wir ja in der Welt
gemeinsam im bot das aufgrund der
Klimakatastrophe der ökologischen
Verheerungen die Menschheit eigentlich
zu einer Art Notgemeinschaft
zusammenbringt und in der Frage des
Überlebens des sauberen Wassers der
Biosphäre da haben wir ja eigentlich
gemeinsame Interessen die gleichzeitig
gemeinsame Werte sind wo es also
zwischen Werten und Interessen
eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied gibt
müssen wir unsere Werte basierte
Außenpolitik stärker auf das Fokussieren
was alle Menschen teilt als das was
verschiedene Kulturen oder Staaten
trennt das ist doch nur eine Neuauflage
der Werte Politik dieser Glaube dass wir
uns nur auf das Klima zu konzentrieren
brauchen wir haben da ein gemeinsames
Problem aber Präsident Putin glaubt dass
der Krieg in der Ukraine für ihn
wichtiger ist als die
Klimapolitik und ich bin sicher dass die
Chinesen die den klimanotstand ja
durchaus erkannt haben der Meinung sind
dass die Förderung ihrer
wirtschaftlichen Interessen im Moment
wichtiger ist das Problem mit den
Gemeingütern besteht darin dass sie zwar
allgemein bekannt sind es aber genau aus
diesem Grund sehr schwierig wird sich
auf sie zu konzentrieren es gibt Studien
die folgendes beweisen wenn es zwei
bedrohungsursachen gibt die eine aus der
Natur und die andere von einem
menschlichen gegenüber dann
konzentrieren sich Menschen auf das
zweite den menschlichen Feind zu glauben
dass wir einfach sagen können lasst uns
die Kriege vergessen lasst uns den
wirtschaftlichen Wettbewerb vergessenüm
uns nur um das Klima das mag ja gute
Dichtung sein ich glaube aber nicht dass
es gute Politik ist Herr krev ich danke
Ihnen für das Gespräch ich danke
[Musik]
Ihnen
connection aborted